[Music]
hey guys do you find yourself
munching mindlessly on your desk here
are 10 healthy and convenient low
calorie snacks which you can make ahead
practice next with you to work or school
to keep you feeling full and avoid -
munching rate based on jujubes are one
of the most popular superfood in
traditional Chinese medicine now combine
that with walnut this snack is packed
with antioxidants fiber and healthy fat
simply slice of the rigid to create a
small pocket remove the seeds and
instead have a walnut into the state
each serving has about 36 calories
consumed four to five servings to keep
hunger at bay
if you crave a chocolate bar click on
one of these instead they are chewy
nutty and sweet but way healthier than
the typical high-fat high-calorie
chocolate bar all you need are three
basic ingredients not the maple syrup
and peanut butter in a pan under low
heat until smooth
don't let it overheat then turn off the
heat and add in the earth you can also
add in other ingredients such as
sunflower seeds and cocoa powder mix
them well then simply shape them into
bite-sized Bowl chill in the fridge for
about 1 hour until firm having just one
oz bowl provides you with only 60
calories and it will satisfy your sweet
tooth
spirit is a great low calorie snack as
only five calories per nori sheet it is
a great alternative over Christmas roll
one sheet with some chops of vegetables
such as carrots cucumber and bell pepper
you can consume them in abundance
without worrying about your waistline
alternatively you can dip the chop some
vegetables into homemade yogurt dip I've
made mine with one cup of Greek yogurt
one minced garlic clove one tablespoon
of freshly squeezed lemon juice a
handful of chopped fresh mint and a
little bit of lemon zest
each tablespoon has less than ten
calories versus 94 calories per
tablespoon of mayo 473 calories per
tablespoon of ranch dressing split peas
are a very public snack in the Indian
culture this piece are high in fiber
protein but low in fat
look one cup of peas for at least four
hours or overnight then drain the water
and pass a dry over medium-high heat
coat the pan with one tablespoon of
olive oil then add in the peas and stir
frequently until good in color and
crunchy in texture for about 7 to 10
minutes remove from pan and allow the
peas to cool down season with a little
bit of chili flakes and so in an
airtight container
another of my favorite possible snacks
are plum stuffed
cherry tomatoes simply slice the
tomatoes to create a pocket and insert
the plum into the tomato this snack is
so convenient and gives you the quick
energy boost you need on the go
instead of buying high sugar flavored
yoga pod make your own with natural
foods slice about half a cup of your
favorite fruits so I set the separate
the fruit from the yogurt to keep them
fresh and you can't have these possible
snack boxes ahead when you're feeling
peckish simply makes the fruit and
yogurt together
instead of spending unnecessary money on
packets trail mix make your own instead
simply choose a combination of nuts
seeds and dried fruit in easy and cheap
nuts are packed with nutrients but they
are calorie dense to avoid snacking on
the entire bag be sure to measure them
out each quarter cup serving has about
114 to 170 calories at only 29 calories
per rice cake
they're a great satisfying low calorie
snack option and you can top them up
with anything you want so a combination
of complex carbs and proteins helps to
keep your blood sugar level stable and
feeling full for longer plus it's gluten
free and the final snack is simply a
hard-boiled egg yep they are hassle free
high in protein and consuming only one
egg can shut your grumbling tummy at
work and keep it going through the day
if you're prepared with your own healthy
snacks you won't be tempted by any
unhealthy snacks at work or school so
try them out and let me know which is
your favorite snack in the comments
below we should attack me as Jonas or
official and hashtag is Jason recipes be
sure to give this video a thumb up share
it and subscribe to my youtube channel
for a lot more healthy recipes all the
best